the brutal murder of one woman Sarah  everard brought into sharp Focus the  everyday violence against hundreds of  thousands of women and girls  from rape offenses to domestic violence  you all deal with domestic abuse on a  daily basis that's the word do you know  what grooming is to the exploitation of  children the online grooming is getting  younger it has now gone into primary  schools it's everywhere they get beaten  not they get raped they get assaulted  they it's they they're they're really  vulnerable can happen to anyone I  thought I was going to die that night  and it's so often under the radar  violence against women and girls has  been described as an epidemic by those  on the front line as the former home  secretary said to me recently there is  inconsistency across different forces in  dealing with the issue so I came to this  one to find out what they're doing